the FBI is investigating a payroll
company that abruptly shut down leaving
more than 250,000 employees across the
country without their money New York
State based my payroll HR allegedly
diverted about thirty five million
dollars from employee checks and
accounts it left many accounts with
negative balances and employers
scrambling to pay their workers our
consumer investigative correspondent
that's Anna Warner shows us the painful
fallout it hurts this isn't something
that we were prepared for Tonya Willis
says her animal rescue shelter is nearly
at a standstill after her payroll
company abruptly shut down all of their
phone lines were down and all of their
social media accounts were wiped off
last week some of Willis's employees
frantically called after finding
recently deposited paychecks just
vanished from their accounts between all
of the employees there was over a
million thirteen thousand dollars
deducted between eight checking accounts
the AP says Willis is one of about five
thousand business owners scrambling to
pay workers after a business partner to
my payroll HR said my payroll HR
diverted an estimated 35 million dollars
from employee accounts some accounts had
multiple withdrawals leaving many
employees with negative balances Willis
says one of her employees accounts was
over drafted nearly 1 million dollars
she had less than a thousand dollars in
that account so we want to know how is
that even possible my payroll HR and its
CEO Michael Mann did not return calls
from CBS News but cash a financial
services a company that worked with my
payroll HR claims it's a victim of fraud
by the company and that man or someone
at my payroll HR manipulated account
numbers and move workers money into a
personal account Willis's shelter
rescues about 200 dogs a year but she
says she can't take in any more until
they get the money back to fund it I
hope that there is a better answer other
than somebody intentionally stole money
and ran away with it
I hope there is a better answer but
right now I just can't think of one the
FBI is asking for any other potentials
it
dunce to come forward good job let's go
for CBS this morning I'm Anna Werner Wow
whatever the answer she gets is not
going to be satisfied no waiting for the
banks doing it involved here and how
this nothing worth in thinking to have
some money in your bank account and it's
not there we go